I finished the last video
touching on the stimulus plan
and whether it's going
to be big enough and
what its intent was.
But I was a little handwavy
about things like savings and
GDP and I thought it would
actually be good to get a
little bit more particular.
This isn't just me
making up things.
So a good place to start
is just to think
about disposable income.
And people talk about it without
ever giving you a good
definition.
It's important to understand
what disposable income is.
So this box right here is GDP,
so it's all the goods and
services, essentially all the
income, that we produce.
The disposable income is
essentially the amount that
ends up in the hands
of people.
So the U.S. GDP, I don't know
what the exact number is, it's
on the order of I think
$15 trillion.
And so some of that money
goes to taxes.
I don't know.
Let's say $3 trillion
ends up in taxes.
And these are round numbers,
but it gives you a sense of
the make-up.
Then maybe about another
$1 trillion is saved by
businesses.
So let's say that I'm Microsoft
and I make a billion
dollars a share.
Microsoft makes a lot more
than that, but I make a
billion dollars.
And I just keep it in a bank
account owned by Microsoft.
I don't give it to
my employees.
I don't dividend it out
to the shareholders.
I just keep that.
So corporate savings,
let's say, is
another trillion dollars.
These are roundabout numbers.
And then everything
left over is,
essentially, disposable income.
I'm making some simplifications
there, but
everything left over is
disposable income.
And the idea is, what is in the
hands of households after
paying their taxes:
disposable income.
That check that you get after
your taxes and everything else
that is taken out of your
paycheck, that money, that is
disposable income to you.
So the interesting thing is
where this disposable income
has been going over the
last many, many years.
So this right here, this
chart, is a plot of the
percentage of disposable income
saved since 1960.
I got this off the Bloomberg
terminal again.
And just so you get a good
reference point, let me draw
the line for 10%.
Because I kind of view that
as a reference point.
That's 10% personal savings.
Actually, you could go back even
further than this, and
you can see from the 1960s all
the way until the early `80s,
the go-go `80s, people were
saving about 10% of their
disposable income.
Of what they got on that
paycheck after paying taxes,
they were keeping about 10% of
it, putting it in the bank.
And, of course, that would later
be used for investment
and things like that.
But then starting in the early
`80s, right around, let's see,
about 1984, you see that people
started saving less and
less money.
All the way to the extreme
circumstance, to 2007, where,
on average, people didn't
save money.
Where maybe I saved $5, but
someone else borrowed $5.
So on average, we didn't
save money.
Actually we went slightly
negative.
And all of this, and this is
kind of my claim-- and it can
be borne out if you look at
other charts in terms of the
amount of credit we took on-- is
because we took on credit.
I guess there's two things
you could talk about.
We took on credit and we started
having what I call
perceived savings, right?
If I buy a share of IBM a lot
of people say, oh, I saved I
saved my money, I'm invested
in the stock market.
But when I bought a share of
IBM, unless that dollar I paid
for the share goes to IBM to
build new factories-- And
that's very seldom time.
Most of the time, that dollar I
gave to buy that IBM share,
just goes to a guy who
sold an IBM share.
So there's no net investment.
It's only investment, it's only
savings, when that dollar
actually goes to invest in some
way, build a new factory
or build a new product
or something.
So I think you had more and more
people thinking that they
were saving when they weren't.
Maybe thinking that they were
saving, as their home equity
in their house grew, or
as their stock market
portfolio went up.
But there wasn't actual
aggregate savings going on.
In fact, if anything, they were
borrowing against those
things, especially
home equity.
And the average savings rate
went down and down and down.
So now we're here in 2007, and
maybe you could say 2008,
where this is the capacity.
We should probably talk about
world capacity, because so
much of what we consume really
does come from overseas, but
this is the capacity serving the
U.S. And let's say, going
into 2007, this was demand.
Supply and demand was, let's
say, pretty evenly matched.
If you go to that top up here,
you see that we were at 80%
utilization, which
isn't crazy.
So if anything, you could say
that demand was maybe right
around here.
But that's a good level.
You want to be at around
80% utilization.
That's the rate at which you
don't have hyperinflation, but
you're utilizing things
quite well.
Now all of a sudden, the credit
crisis hit and all this
credit disappears.
And I'd make the argument that
the only thing that enabled us
to not save this money,
is more and more
access to cheap credit.
Every time we went through a
recession, from the mid `80s,
onwards, the government
solution was to
make financing easier.
The Fed would lower
interest rates.
We would pump more and
more money into
Fannie and Freddie Mac.
We would lower standards
on what it
took to get a mortgage.
We would create incentives
for securitization.
We would look the other way when
Bear Stearns is creating
collateralized debt obligations,
or AIG is writing
credit default swaps.
And all of that enabled
financing.
Until we get to this point right
here, where everything
starts blowing up.
So you essentially have
forced savings.
When people can't borrow
anymore, the savings rate has
to go to 10% because most of
this is just from people
taking on more credit.
There were a group of people
who were probably already
always saving at 10% of their
disposable income.
But there's another group of
people who were more than
offsetting that by
taking credit.
Now that the credit crisis hits,
you're going to see the
savings rate-- and you already
see it with this blip right
there-- the savings rate is
going to go back up to 10% of
disposable income.
Now if the savings rate goes
back to 10% of disposable
income, that amount of money,
that 10% of disposable income,
this gap, is 10% of disposable
income that cannot be used for
consumption.
And let's think about how large
of an amount that is.
Right now, the U.S. disposable
income, if I were to draw
disposable income-- this number
right here, I just
looked it up-- it's around $10.7
trillion, let's say $11
trillion for roundabout.
So this 10% of disposable income
that we're talking
about, this gap between the
normal environment, the
environment that was enabled
from super-easy credit, that's
10% of disposable income.
10% of $11 trillion is $1.1
trillion per year of demand
that will go away.
That's per year.
So all of a sudden, you're going
to have a gap where this
was the demand before
and now the demand's
going to drop to here.
And all of this $1.1 trillion
of demand is going to
disappear, because credit
is now not available.
And then you do get a situation
where you might hit
a low capacity utilization.
Unfortunately, the capacity
utilization numbers don't go
back to the Great Depression,
and we could probably get a
sense of, at what point
does a deflationary
spiral really get triggered.
But because that $1.1 trillion
in demand disappears, you're
going to see this orange line
just drop lower and lower in
terms of capacity utilization.
And that's going to
drive prices down.
And what Obama and the Fed and
everyone else is trying to do,
is to try to make up this gap.
Now, everyone else can't
borrow money.
Companies can't borrow money.
Homeowners can't borrow money.
But the government can borrow
money, because people are
willing to finance it.
At the bare minimum, the Fed's
willing to finance the
government.
And so the government wants to
come in and take up the slack
with this demand and
spend the money
themselves with the stimulus.
Now we just talked about, what's
the magnitude of this
demand shock?
It's $1.1 trillion per year.
While the stimulus plan
is on the order
of a trillion dollars.
And that trillion dollars isn't
per year, although I
have a vague feeling that we
will see more of them coming
down the pipeline.
This stimulus plan that just
passed is expected to be spent
over the next few years.
So in terms of demand created
over the next few years, it's
going to be several hundred
billion per year.
So it's not going to be anywhere
near large enough to
make up for this demand shock.
So we're still going to have
low capacity utilization.
So the people who argue that
these stimulus plans are going
to create hyperinflation, I
disagree with that, at least
in the near term, because in
the near term it's nowhere
near large enough to really
soak up all of the extra
capacity we have
in the system.
And if anything, it's going to
soak up different capacity.
So the stimulus plan might
create inflationary-like
conditions in certain markets
where the stimulus plan is
really focused.
But in other areas, where you
used to have demand, but the
stimulus plan doesn't touch,
like $50 spatulas from
Williams Sonoma or granite
countertops, that area is
going to continue to
see deflation.
And I would say net-net, since
this thing this is actually so
small, even though we're talking
about trillion dollars
relative to the amount of demand
destroyed per year,
we'll probably still
have deflation.
And, for anyone who's paying
close attention to it, and I
am because I care about these
things, the best thing to keep
a lookout for, to know when to
start running to gold maybe or
being super-worried about
inflation, is if you see this
utilization number creeping back
up into the 80% range.
At least over the last 40 years,
that's been the best
leading indicator to
say when are we
going to have inflation.
And for all those goldbugs out
there, who insist that all of
the hyperinflation or the
potential hyperinflation is
caused by our not being on the
gold standard, I just want to
point out that you can very
easily have-- we went off of
Bretton Woods and completely
went to a fiat currency in
'73, that right around here.
But our worst inflation bouts
were actually while we were on
the gold standard.
And that's because we had very
high capacity utilization.
This is the war period.
What happens during a war?
You run your factories
all-out.
You run your farms all-out
to feed the troops.
The factories, instead of
building cars, build planes.
Everyone was working.
Wages go up.
Everything goes up and
you have inflation.
A lot of people say, oh, the
war was the solution to the
Great Depression.
And it is true in that it got
us out of that negative
deflationary spiral
that I talked
about in the last video.
And it did it by creating an
unbelievable amount of inflation.
And then after the war, you
could argue what allowed-- I
don't have GDP here, but the
U.S. GDP really did do well in
the postwar period-- it wasn't
the war per se, although the
war kind of did take us out of
the deflationary spiral.
So after the war, you had
all of this capacity,
after World War II.
So you had all this capacity
that was being used up by the
war, and then, all of the
sudden, the war ends.
And you're like, well, we don't
have to build planes
anymore, we don't have to feed
the troops anymore, and now we
have all these unemployed troops
who come back home.
What are we going
to do with them?
You'd say maybe, capacity
utilization would come back
down there.
But what a lot of people don't
talk about is, the rest of the
industrial world's capacity
was blown to smithereens.
At that point in time, the U.S.
was a smaller part of GDP
and the other major players
were Germany,
Western Europe and Japan.
In the U.S., we didn't have
any factories bombed.
The entire war took place
in these areas.
And whenever people go on
bombing raids, the ideal thing
that they want to bomb
is factories.
So what you had in the postwar
period, is you had all of
these countries that had their
capacity blown to smithereens.
The U.S. was essentially the
only person left with any
capacity, and so all the demand
from the rest of the
world picked up the slack
in the U.S. capacity.
And that's why, even though
there was a demand shock in
the U.S. after that, you also
had a supply shock from the
war where you had all of this
capacity that was blown to
smithereens.
In this situation that we
are in now, we have a
major demand shock.
Financing just disappears and
the savings rate's going to
skyrocket because people
can't borrow anymore.
But there's no counteracting
supply shock.
Supply of factories making
widgets and all the rest is
staying the same.
So the Obama administration is
trying to create a stimulus to
sop some of this up, but it's
not going to be enough.
And my only fear is, with all
the printing money and all
that goes, once we do get
back to the 80% capacity
utilization, once we do go back
here, how quickly they
can unwind all of this printing
press money and all
of the stimulus plan.
Because that's going
to be the key.
Because, if we do get to 80%
capacity utilization or we
start pushing up there, and we
continue to run the printing
press-- because that's what,
essentially, government's
incentive is to do, because they
always feel better when
we're flush with money-- then,
and only then, you might see a
hyperinflation scenario.
But I don't see that at least
for the next few years.